it's film I'm not here which is in
theaters and on demand today and talk
about only those subjects JK Simmons
back here on the Rich Eisen shared I I
remember to remember this show being a
little more all-encompassing you know
it's it's funny baseball only
pop-culture baseball only how are you
I'm fine
despite the prospects for my baseball
team this year was nice to see a little
little mags flashbang flashback gee
Leland's given the one to the wife and
kids and yeah it's beautiful you know
way back in the day you've got the old
English D on the time every year the
away cap because I'm away from I like
that and yeah it's gonna be watching the
kids I don't know I mean you know Mickey
said he's decent visions finishing his
career there you never know please yeah
yeah I came out and said that I think
just a couple of days ago McGee and the
kids I mean there's you know something
to be said for watching you know much in
the prospects you ever know though right
yeah no absolutely that's their that's
the 2019 Detroit Tigers you never know
you never know you might win a ball game
for the Lakers right you never know
alright so let's get to it alright
switching hats many nights JK Simmons
Thank You last time you are here you're
like I don't think so I don't know I
feel bad I don't like it Oh 60 plus
points later
look at you oh my gosh we got back here
on the show I can I cannot say I did not
think of you
terrific that trouncing I was like God
if I'd have just gone in there have been
super confident cocky you know
but I you know I will see we'll see
we'll see yeah I'm at some point yeah
the rivalry oh gosh will actually become
a rivalry again I don't know oh come on
now hold on a second you didn't see
coming you didn't think it was gonna
happen and it did I thought it would be
a real competitive 92 football I didn't
see an athletic competition in time it's
funny what during that game I have not
seen you since I'll tell the story I
told her here but I'll tell you I'll
tell it again for those who will indulge
I saw the way it was matriculating yes
and repeatedly up and down tell the
story I'm sorry go ahead
62 points Jake stop it yeah so the way
it was unfolding I had my two of my
three kids that were there normally I
needed to have my own space and take the
kids out whatever but they were coming
in and I decided to just throw myself
into the love and the nurturing of my
children who just wanted to play these
games nor normally during a Michigan
Ohio State football game no time for
games
there's only one game B game this time
though got down on the floor played a
little you know matching game with them
I just threw myself into the love of my
children that's a beautiful thing but
it's such a touching story and at the
same time they were learning a lesson in
how to lose which is an important lesson
that we all must learn I know in life
you're not wrong you're not wrong you
got to learn you got to learn to keep
that stiff-upper-lip so let me tell you
this story as well
JK Simmons here on the rich choices show
at the Super Bowl this year in Atlanta
and I bet I got the the golden ticket
invitation from the Commissioner of the
National Football League Roger Goodell -
watching his very nice posh digs inside
and it's but it's a sign CD so there's
two rows of comfy seats and then the bar
seating in the back
got a bar seat and the person who is
sitting right in front of me in the
compass yet I look down on a piece of
paper and I look at my seat I'm like oh
my gosh the person sitting in front of
me Urban Meyer I've heard of him so I go
up to Roger Goodell and I'm like you
know Commissioner I know you're a busy
man you're a busy man I'm sure you're
not taking part in the seating chart of
of this affair but did I do something
wrong piss you off as I need to figure
it out he just looks at me because sit
down and enjoy this so first quarter
guess who sits down turns around says
couldn't have been nicer couldn't have
been more because he's a Buckeye is that
what is there a nice breed of piece that
writer cuz I find that sometimes so what
do you think about Ryan day now sir what
do you think yeah I mean you know
relatively unproven but I have a lot of
confidence there I think you know we had
Luke fickle when when Luke maybe wasn't
quite ready and now he's proven that he
is and yes Cincinnati and yeah I hope
bug and it's a brand new day I like it
in Columbus is that gonna be the phrase
on the unknown well that's the phrase on
my tax gain with the lang brothers you
know my my Ohio State okay homie okay
yeah yeah brand new day no I'm looking
forward to it and I always always always
you're rebooting you know we get what
for sure two first rounders maybe maybe
more this year
well well for sure Bosa and and Haskins
they're not gonna have a very long first
night of the draft right that is for
sure
yeah and then all those kids shown up
and they just blazed a trail down the
40-yard dash line it was read
Harrison the boys the iris and the boys
and then unfortunately that kid the
defensive back but I think Morehead is
his name he popped a peck the day before
he might have been the fastest one of
them all if he was able to run so using
all of my professionalism to go through
all this I found it interesting though
that Ryan days first act was to tell
Schiano we're done and then tell Tate
are tell we're done - and get that kid
from Georgia yeah that surprise you -
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know and we we
don't know all the you know workings
obviously but he's made a lot of great
hires in the mean time and and like I
said you're always rebooting at a place
like Ohio State so I'm I'm all for a
reboot so okay let me get to your film
I'm not here okay so now you got another
hat here we go I'm not here it's
fantastic by the way done it's branding
its props its I'm liking it I'm like
everything okay so it's a film about a
gentleman who relives parts of his life
sometimes difficult other times not so
joyous yes so it would be like me
staring at a picture of the John Cooper
years at Ohio State and having
everything come back to me about all
these wonderful amount of times that a
good analogy there are aspects of that
in the form and more of it from my
characters perspective would be like you
watching the Jim Tressel year okay into
the urban mind I see now we're giving
people a great sense of what this films
all about absolutely and your wife
directed you in this film
my wife Michelle Schumacher co-wrote and
co-produced and directed and edited the
movie fantastic yes and and I have
believe me III I don't know how
grown-ups do those kinds of things you
know because I show up and pretend to be
somebody else right but to wear all
those hats was it full circle yeah was
it's a remarkable achievement what it's
a beautiful movie what is it like being
directed by your wife it is as I believe
you alluded to earlier much like life at
home performing as directed honestly in
this case because because my character
is very sort of vulnerable and and naked
yes and and to be directed by the person
that I
trust implicitly was was a real blessing
in this case right and your daughter
appears in the film a daughter who was
foolishly determined that she wants to
be an actor Michelle and I met doing
Broadway so you know she had it coming
from both sides yes it was inevitable
she appears very briefly in the movie
just you know to get her feet wet she
paired in a couple of Michelle's short
films mm-hmm when she was a little kid
and our son contributed some music to
the soundtrack which comes soul from
also your side of the family right yeah
well yeah both Michelle and I you know
come from a musical background and yeah
whiplash was not a complete accident
well no no you play when you came on to
talk about that many moons ago and winds
ago yeah that your dad was a music
teacher correct at the Ohio State
University right so that's why I brought
that up so yeah I have I have a
photographic memory of your life you
know and my many many many victories oh
my gosh but it's it's a neat movie and
people should all seek it out it's in
select theaters an on-demand today and
here locally your wife and you and your
wife we're gonna have a QA and that is
on Sunday at the lammily theatre in
Santa Monica this after the 5:30
screening okay so if you're around town
here in Sunday I know we're on locally
here in Los Angeles and throughout the
Southern California area come and go to
Lana Lee comm to get tickets to all of
that and okay I've got a start bench cut
to play with JK Simmons here on the Rich
Eisen show if you don't mind going to be
quiet I know this is not your first
start bench cut for a on the Rich Eisen
show you must start one bench one and
cut one okay there we go for items for
JK Simmons again I'm not here in
theaters near you and also on demand
today let's get to it first one if you
had it win one game for the college
football championship who would be the
coach Woody Hayes Urban Meyer or Jim
Tressel's start bench Oh caught JK's now
it's a toss-up I'm gonna I'm gonna start
trestle really start the vest
and and I'm gonna and I'm gonna bench
urban and and I mean you got it
you know Clemson you got a cut woody
yeah we got to make sure that you really
got a control okay yeah really Jim
Tressel wonderful I love trestle so much
I mean yeah and there was you know one
game in which he was famously you know
terrible the you know the right the big
national championship game in Florida
but but I mean he was he was an Ohio
State legend say you would start trestle
bench urban and tattoo Woody Hayes I
mean these are not easy choices he
didn't he didn't get the tattoo okay
[Music]
next up honor if you heard our segment
before all these rule changes in
baseball that are being instituted in
the Atlanta and the Atlanta like you
heard about that you don't like some of
these
I don't baseball's not broken why are we
fixing Thank You Jay case right I mean
can we just not completely succumb to
the lack of attention span of our
children I like I said I don't think it
is a time of play or pace of play it's a
quality of play issue potentially in
pace well which it depends on which
issue you're talking right it's to me so
I've got three three four you start
bench cut pitchers have to face at least
three batters twenty second pitch clock
add the D H to the National League start
bench cut I'm gonna start adding the D H
even though I like the distinct
difference between leagues because I
just hate the other two so much I like
that I'm gonna bench the pitch o'clock
and I'm gonna I'm gonna cut the you have
to be three batters I mean I don't mind
there's some strategy in the game you
know and then I I get that there would
be a new sort of level of that strategy
but you know I mean go get a hot dog
during the pitching change go to the
bathroom have a conversation have a
conversation with your play on the floor
with your kids you know I mean certainly
when there's a blow off being take
seriously yes when the contest is one
side all right most obnoxious fans in
baseball o bench cut Yankees Red Sox
Cubs ha Yankees Red Sox Cubs
it actually is close
but but I'm not gonna not say the
Yankees are the most obnoxious fans in
baseball so I'm gonna starting Yankee
fans a very close second and ready to
jump up off the bench at any moment
would be the Red Sox fans and then I you
know in honor of my cousin we'd I will I
will
bench the Cubs fans cousin cousin we'd
okay there's a lifelong Cubs fan okay
and you know you used to have to add the
term long-suffering yes of course
they're not actually he and I were at
Game five and Wrigley what was that two
and a half years ago when they went sent
it to made sure to send it back I sent
it back to Cleveland yeah you know they
used to say long-suffering Red Sox fans
too not anymore
yeah let me dig into this here just for
a little quick second okay
what's what's so obnoxious about Yankee
fans there's sort of innate sense of
superiority there they're like entitled
like so many of the going down a bad
road here so many people in my
children's generation yeah like you're
born on third base you act like you hit
a triple I mean a triple like Joe
Girardi over the head of Greg Maddux to
win at the time I think of his World
Series championship 22 it's now up to 27
all-time between the you get the Tigers
very good March 8th yeah an all-time
postseason record head to head Detroit
New York Yankees all-time all-time
Yankees have more all-time head to head
Detroit Tigers versus New York Yankees
in the postseason oh you and I don't
know that off the top my head you really
do it would be to a no Detroit one of
what you just show well just because
they after we vanquished the Yankees
then we beat this is because the Yankees
constantly have generational talents
that grow on trees that come out of the
worked like that judging by for a
billion dollars all right I've been
trying to avoid bench cut created by our
Courtney producer Don Bowie but I will
ask it because I love our guests here to
judge is hard to not like about Lee and
I appreciate is an exception to the rule
okay last one for just like Jeter right
[Music]
[Laughter]
how do you grow up a Yankee fan
he's just there's just something wrong
that's just not right Michigan coach
team you'd want Ohio State to face the
most Jim Harbaugh Rich Rodriguez or
Brady Howe so you talk about that team
up north that shall remain nameless like
it's like saying Baltimore so I'm gonna
start Harbaugh because he's he's my
favorite guy in the universe to be I
mean even without the silly pants you
know but to beat those pants off of him
every it's like she knew that the Ohio
State players when they beat Michigan
I'm sorry team up north when when they
win that game that they get the golden
pants is like their little trophy so
he's wearing the golden pants that we
can just take right off of him on an
annual basis him so I scarred him and
then really a pretty close second would
be rich rod cuz he was he was also very
fun to beat Brady Hulk I don't know he
actually just seemed like he was ready
to leave he got the interim we didn't
have a headset on so we didn't know what
was happening
great to see you and you as always as
long as the street keeps going it's
always gonna be fun full you went full
like whole town think we can do it no I
mean I'm gonna talk up the opponent and
then all of a sudden 60 burger later
you're back with a big smile 52 I mean
who's counting what do you got over
there does it do it as we hold
I'm not doing this little no great to
see you sir again I'm not here is in
select theaters and on demand a special
film not just because your wife co-wrote
it and directed and yours your daughter
appears in it and your son had a lot to
do with the music in it it's just a
beautiful film that you you know if
you're having a midlife crisis probably
not the best film to see I'll be honest
no maybe it is because at the end of the
day it's a thoughtful and hopeful and
beautiful story I guess I shouldn't
probably pitching a film saying this is
not the movie for you to see it is the
movie for you to see I apologize again
I'm just working so I like pitching from
you know 60 20 feet that is a that's
nuts come on that we're moving the mound
back two feet yeah now let's start the
ninth inning with the bases loaded right
now you know well and I don't like the
guy on second base a lot of these these
rules no but the sixty-two I think once
half that league comes down with Tommy
John surgery because they're trying to
figure out what the extra two feet looks
like on their fastball or whatever but
again I'm not here QA with JK Simmons
and and your wife Michelle Schumacher on
Sunday Sunday after the 5:30 right here
in Santa Monica check that out
thank you for coming on bro thank you
thank you got it alright sir before you
leave JK Simmons if you would not mind
indulging I have a symbol here that Mike
del 2 felt picked up I'd love to do
we've been thinking about this every
single time I'm like can we have him do
it we throw it at him no I love free to
autograph it and we'll put it up in our
studio happily I'm sure this is not the
first symbol you've been asked to
autograph right that is a true fact okay
but it oddly started dunno what four
years ago or so alright and I guess if
you don't mind you know not quite my
tempo or something along those lines
unless you want to personalize it in a
way that will make me upset and I
rushing or am i dragging yes
here we go this will hold a nice place
in our studio here since it the color
scheme actually does man it's kind of
magic everything going on alright let's
see what it is there we go as director I
appreciate that here it is JK Simmons is
autographed and let's put it there not
quite my tempo
there it is love it fantastic thank you
sir for doing that
my pleasure I really appreciate that all
ad-lib by the way that entire movie was
ad-lib Damian didn't write any of that
given all this credit like you some
genius whatever and I and you're doing
old by the way let's get this plug in
real quick you're gonna be in the next
season of Rock Meyer - right oh yes I am
indeed with the the lovely and talented
Hank Azaria he's so genius on that show
and I get to come in and sort of recur a
few times as a guy that Brock Meyers not
not my favorite guy so you like right I
play Matt the bat Matt the bat that's
Jeff yeah our favorite thing last year
is that we did actually try to drum up
the Brock Meyer Brent Musburger feud
between the two of them and Musburger
played along like he called he called in
and he just started talking about how
Jimmy would just get drunk and vomit all
over the place and he's well he's got a
beautiful Bob Costas moment in the the
preview came out and it's the the reveal
that Brock Meyer tells cost as he gave
him pinkeye and so she she I don't want
to give away too much more it's pretty
great it's so are you sir come back
anytime come back in my shell Thank You
Simmons again check out I'm not here
coming up tonight so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience